I have all these ideas in my head and I
don't get started whose opinions do you
think you value the most probably not
parents have you ever had a real combo
with them I tried but she's not
listening she's blocking it yeah not
being accountable yes I actually believe
that that puts you in an even better
spot if at the end of the day a parent
is delusional about it and and it hurts
too much it's not about judging them
that they don't see it it's about being
empathetic and compassionate to her
because don't forget she was parented
yes your grandparents existed and I see
it in her siblings as well that all hell
all have the same issues it makes sense
so instead of judging her be
compassionate to her which then will
allow you to be the compassion to
yourself and will give you an
opportunity to actually jump and do it